all right Zan
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally Jackson New Jersey
tell me about your family
um I grew up with
a
my brother Alex my sister Katie my mom
and dad my dad was a junkie all through
my life I'm gonna sell my coma pretty
much my whole childhood
and
um
when I was 11 I called the cops on my
dad for trying to kill my brother and he
threw me out I ended up getting gang
raped and his response to it was oh
you're in pain here let me Crush you up
a Roxy 30. and he got me addicted to
Roxy's and fed my opiate habit for the
next four years until I discovered
heroin
and then I went into that
um I was a band kid marching band I
played the trumpet lacrosse track
all that and then I went to Beauty
School got ten cosmetology licenses I
owned a barber shop for five years
until I went into um
I had a brain aneurysm blow
they had to remove my scope to let my
brain swell
and I lost the barbershop because I'm
paralyzed on my left side now
I haven't been on the streets pretty
much my whole life
been abducted six times gang raped five
times
been through pretty much everything
under the sun
my family has actually recently mourned
me that I thought I was dead so they had
a memorial service for me
I've tried to kill myself nine times in
the past year
and I've never won anything more I've
just been wishing it was over for so
long
and it's just so much
are you still in contact with your
family no they don't talk to you or you
don't talk to them oh I have a phone I
don't have any way to contact them
but are you in good good terms with them
or I'm so so my mom will answer the
phone if I call her but
my brothers won't pick up and my sister
I have
me and my sister were attached to the
hip and now she doesn't
talk to me but it's okay is that because
you're the drug addiction the drug
addiction also caused my brother Alex
just had a baby and I'm not allowed to
see it
and
I used that all crystal
and if I can find crack
when did you come to Los Angeles
um
painful Los Angeles for the first time
about two two and a half years ago
and then
I was lost on skid row and my brother
Adam my half brother Adam came and
hunted me down he L.A watched the
newscasters help him find helps him find
me he handed me down probably back to
Florida put me back in the Streetman
Center
I got locked up for 18 months
and then I flew back out here
where do you stay where do you sleep
wherever I want usually under some sort
of tarp like
tent set up
most nights
how do you support yourself
tricking okay whoring pretty much pays
for everything
my only really option
do you have children no I always wanted
a note
the time I was a little girl like you
know when you're little and they say
make a poster but you want to be when
you grow up I always wanted to be a mom
but I'm not
I don't think anyone would want me to be
their mother now anyway
You're Gonna Love Before yeah I've been
engaged a few times
dear friends
kind of
these people on the street people on the
street but the people out here you know
they want to see you do good but never
better than them
that's a real shame
I've replaced everything in my life more
times than I can count
it's been strip bare
I was stripped but naked on Washington
Boulevard and call Culver City because I
had on some kids t-shirt like
what emotions do you go through living
this life
I feel like it's been most of my life in
a psychosis
extremely bipolar
and a lot of anxiety disorders like
trichotillomania which makes me ripped
my hair out
and [ __ ] OCD PTSD
what is your drug now
crystal meth and Fentanyl
[Music]
what's your biggest fear what are you
afraid of now my only fear really is
that I'm gonna end up with half of a
face
I'm trying to blow my brains out
because I like I said I tried to kill
myself certain times and failed
other than that I'm not really afraid of
anything
what emotions do you go through
you get depressed or depression
suicidalization
um
this major anxiety
and well I had a lot of blackouts for my
PTSD
and your paralysis is from
the aneurysm and stroke I can't move my
left arm at all was that caused by the
drugs
yeah I was shooting a lot of speed balls
there's your Coke and heroin
and I had a rupture in my brain
and all the blood vessels in my brain
popped
and no one was talking to me at the time
because I was telling heroin
and I got left alone for three days
before they found me
there's so much blood on my brain there
to cut open my scalp or remove my skull
I lived without a skull for seven months
before they able to put it back on
wow
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done things
differently
yeah I had a
scholarship to Yale for chemistry and I
turned down to the heroines were
important I also was invited to be in
the Navy Band playing the trumpet and I
said [ __ ] the man he didn't want any
part of the military and the military
would have set me up a lot better in
life
is this your lowest point right now you
think
I don't know about that I've been pretty
low before but I've come to a conclusion
as of recently
that a person's worth is not determined
on how high they can climb but how high
they bounce when they hit the bottom
so
I'm trying to do that so you're
optimistic
yeah
my best and worst qualities my
stubbornness
I never really stopped
you have good memories of your childhood
[Music]
living on the streets is tough for a
female what I mean extremely you must
have been followed every day
have you tried to quit
the drugs
oh yeah I've been to treatment over 60
times
really
you think this is something you
inherited from your
have you done definitely my dad was an
addict his brothers were all addicts and
my dad's mom killed herself drinking
just drunk herself to death
as did her five brothers
you think there's a better chance you'll
die on the streets or get clean
um
both are
possible
um
my dad used to tell me the lucky ones
die early because they don't have to
suffer
and I always prayed for that but
is your dad still alive no
he died like
almost two years ago now
COPD his lungs collapsed on him
I was the only one took care of them
and I would give him his morphine but
most of the time I would take this
Ativan from a sugar pill
I just kicked caught up in maintenance
and Subutex maintenance cold turkey on
the street which is
a woman carry on after
going through some of the things you
went through
this is my struggle
I've had a therapist tell me I was like
a garbage Pusher because I compact so
much [ __ ]
to deal with
Dan what would you say is the most
important lesson you learned in your
life
just don't stop
keep pushing
I'm like you would have said do or do
not there is no try
that's a really important lesson
all right Sam thank you so much for
sharing your story
I wish you the best of luck out here all
right thank you thank you